♪ IT'S THE NIGGAR FAMILY ♪
♪ WE ALL KNOW
WHO THEY ARE ♪
♪ FRANK, TIM
AND EMILY ♪
♪ TEACHING
TIM HOW TO RIDE A BIKE ♪
♪ THESE ARE THE NIGGARS
THAT WE LIKE ♪
♪ N-I-G, G-A-R ♪
♪ IT'S THE NIGGAR FAMILY ♪
♪ IT'S THE
NIGGAR FAMILY ♪
♪ YEAH ♪♪
♪♪
BREAKFAST
IS SERVED.
LOOK, HON, MY SISTER
JUST HAD ANOTHER BABY.
LOOK AT THIS LITTLE
BUNDLE OF JOY.
SHE'S GOT THOSE
NIGGAR LIPS.
I KNOW, SO THIN.
IS TIM STILL
ASLEEP ?
( Emily )
I THINK SO.
HE SURE IS ONE
LAZY NIGGAR.
GOOD MORNING,
MOM.
MORNING, DAD.
GOOD MORNING.
YOU KNOW, TIM, WE'RE HAVING
A DINNER PARTY TONIGHT.
I TRUST YOU'LL
BE HERE.
OH, I CAN'T.
I HAVE MY FIRST BIG DATE
WITH JENNY HALSTEAD.
OH.
JENNY HAS A DATE TONIGHT WITH
THE NIGGAR BOY FROM SCHOOL.
WHAT ?
OH, GOD,
NO !
NO, DADDY,
THAT'S HIS NAME.
TIMMY NIGGAR.
OH, OF COURSE,
THAT NIGGAR.
HE'S A VERY GOOD
ATHLETE AND SO WELL-SPOKEN.
THAT FAMILY'S
GOING PLACES.
I MEAN, WE'RE RICH.
THEY'RE
NIGGAR RICH.
OH, BILL.
MORNIN',
NIGGARS !
WHY, IT'S CLIFTON,
OUR COLORED MILKMAN.
AND THIS IS MY FAVORITE FAMILY
TO DELIVER MILK TO.
THE NIGGARS !
MMM-MM !
SOMETHIN' SHO'
SMELLS GOOD.
YOU NIGGARS
COOKIN' ?
WE SURE ARE.
THERE'S SOME LEFTOVER
BACON IF YOU'D LIKE SOME.
OOH, NONE
FOR ME.
I KNOW BETTER THAN TO
GET BETWEEN A NIGGAR
AND THEIR PORK.
MIGHT GET
MY FINGERS BIT.
( laughing )
HERE YOU GO.
I, I HATE TO
BOTHER YOU ABOUT THIS.
BUT, UH, WELL, YOU DIDN'T
PAY YOUR BILL LAST WEEK.
AND I KNOW HOW
FORGETFUL YOU NIGGARS ARE
WHEN IT COMES TO
PAYING BILLS.
GOLLY, CLIFTON,
IT SLIPPED MY MIND.
HERE YOU GO.
SORRY ABOUT
THAT.
OH, NIGGAR,
PLEASE.
NIGGAR, PLEASE !
WELL, TAKE CARE,
MR. "N" WORD.
I HAVE A HOT DATE
WITH THE WIFE TONIGHT.
ALL RIGHT,
TAKE CARE.
PEACE, NIGGAR.
( audience laughing )
NIGGARS !
♪♪
( man )
STEVENSON, PARTY OF FOUR.
UH, STEVENSON,
PARTY OF FOUR.
TABLE FIVE, PLEASE.
BON APPETIT.
NIGGAR, PARTY OF TWO,
NIGGAR, PARTY OF TWO.
LOOKIE HERE,
JACK !
JUST BECAUSE
WE'RE COLORED, DOESN'T MEAN
WE CAME OUT HERE TO BE
DISRESPECTED, OKAY ?
UH, WE'RE THE
NIGGAR FAMILY.
OH, HI, CLIFTON.
OH, WELL, HELLO,
LITTLE NIGGAR.
THESE ARE THE NIGGARS
I WAS TELLING YOU ABOUT.
ARE YOU THE NIGGAR
THAT BROKE THE BOTTLE
OVER RONNIE'S HEAD AT
THE DICE GAME ?
NO, NOT THAT NIGGAR.
THE NIGGAR
FROM WORK.
THE MILK ROUTE.
OH, OKAY.
HAVE
A NICE MEAL.
I BET YOU'LL GET
THE FINEST TABLE
A NIGGAR'S EVER
GOT IN THIS RESTAURANT.
( laughing )
OOH, WHEE !
OH, LORD, THIS RACISM
IS KILLING ME INSIDE.
( doorbell ringing )
WELL, HONEY, PUT YOUR
DINNER PARTY FACE ON.
( Frank )
HELLO.
WELL, YOU MUST
BE THE WETBACKS.
IT'S SANCHEZ.
AND DON'T CALL US
WETBACKS, NIGGAR.
WE FIND IT
OFFENSIVE.
I'M JUST KIDDING,
WE ARE THE WETBACKS.
( laughing )
WAIT'LL WE
TELL THE JEWS.
OH, YOU'RE ONE
CRAZY NIGGAR.
♪ N-I-G,
G-A-R ♪
♪ IT'S THE NIGGAR
FAMILY ♪
♪ IT'S THE
NIGGAR FAMILY ♪♪
NIGGARS !
♪♪